okay for people joining this
live stream starting a little bit late
here
uh this is about neural networks and
explainable
ai kinds of things
yeah actually not so much neural network
we have something about umar talk at the
end but it was not the important stuff
okay so this is
okay so this is a way to us assign
causes to decisions basically it's a way
to say
why a decision was made the way it was
made yes
right yes exactly
okay which group of pixels can change
this hound into a
a hair or something um
okay i get it i understand the points
this is okay so this is
all right
for twelve two well yeah
so this is the very very popular way to
assign contribution to features
and um so you can discuss by the way
it works if you want um
and uh in terms of design
it's actually the most popular it's
incredible how it's like
three four years old it already has like
i don't know thousands of situations
um everybody loves it and
so it's called shop which stands for
sharply additive explanation and the way
we would
use it is the property of predictor
function
classifier function so just like just
like
top probabilities exactly exactly
and i think the key that we
figured out by exploring designs is that
the the output should actually have the
same structure
the same container as the as the example
like for example here you have a data
set and it actually
each numeric value it replace
it with its sharp contribution
um and well i might argue that you
should add another column but i don't
know whether you
what do you do in the case of pixels for
example exactly
exactly that's that's the thing so this
is a
uh we we haven't implemented the pixel
one so this is just now that's cute
yeah so you know color level exactly
and although you probably should use a
black white level because that way you
can just read it out directly
except you have negative and positive so
it's important
um do we have somebody from the english
processing team here
can somebody comment on it it's not
obvious to me how you should do this
yeah uh let me have somebody from them
team matrix plot does that pretty well
okay i'm asking
because it's going to be to you're
trying to make it in a right why don't
we try and find
shoddy or somebody else for memories
processing please sure yeah we'll try to
grab them
because if you're really going to do
this right back mechanism right it's got
to actually work
oh okay okay you mean for the image okay
yeah we're just saying
for the style for the style yeah
yes yeah the problem is it is just an
image
then right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i don't think you should call it
explanation i think what you should do
is call it something like
um
[Music]
what should you call it
because i can imagine that one wants to
put these two things together here
the actual predictor and the um it's
like top probabilities it's like
in top probabilities you have the actual
things
and you have their probabilities which
you do
here fixed acidity that's contribution
volatility no
no i understand but these are the values
that have come out of the predictor
right and this is the the assignments
these are those yeah that's one example
we're
figuring out how much each feature in
the example contributed to its
prediction
well i'm sorry but by the way can you
adjust your audio please
jesse so that we don't hear a bunch of
background nonsense
the um the okay
what does this actually okay so here we
go let's just run this again
this is supposed to run in 12 1 or not
no
then i asked you that at the beginning
of this meeting and i said i said
there's nothing to run
yeah oh and there's nothing around at
all so i can't run no i mean yes
in in jessie's uh thing there's
something to run but that's it
okay all right fine but but then so this
is this is making a predictive function
the predictor function takes what as
input
this is one example i i know i know so
it's taking
this association as input right exactly
and association
what's the output what is the normal
output the output
is a number one number okay
all right okay okay so this is the
explanation for that one number
just like if i say okay exactly right
right
so if i do this and i say image identify
of that thing comma and then i say
i don't know top probabilities is that
is that an option for image identify
i don't think it's like that
okay so let's say i say classify this
as a notable person for example
yeah this will work right
it'll give kind of a stupid answer right
who knows what it'll say who it'll say
that is
why is it so slow i've noticed and
particularly in 12
2 i've noticed really slow
initial i mean this is not that i think
yeah
i mean actually it might but no you
would say download thing i think is the
display of the entity
okay all right so here what it's doing
it's
not very confident of any of them but
this is the same type of thing
this is giving the entity and its
probabilities
right so
in principle here
you know you could want all three of
those things you could want
the the the wine identified or whatever
it was
right for classify you can do this for
classified presumably as well right
yeah yeah okay you might want three
things you might want
what what wine is identified what
probability it assigned to that
and for that
result right you could have this
explanation array is that correct
yeah yeah and you can put that in the
list if you want to have the three
in one shot right and what's this
average down here
this is not supposed to be there
okay all right fine this might be the
total
total actually we could no
no that's not supposed to be there so
average it's the
average wine quality across the data set
so exactly it has nothing to do with
this if you add the entire
column you will get the predicted
quality of that wine example
this is the additive part of the shapley
additive example
i'm sorry adding these numbers
you know i'm not as challenged
arithmetically as the younger generation
probably
adding those numbers does not give this
correct if we add
all of them including the average then
we get
five point something or six point
something which is what we would get if
we put this example into the predictor
function itself
okay so i'm trying to understand then
what these numbers mean
so if if we had a
linear model it's just these are the
coefficients of
um sort of like the coefficients so if
we took
the example this wine and put it into
our predictor
it might estimate a wine quality of
six and what is contributing to that six
well it's starting with nothing else the
average
quality of wine is 5.87 and then
the fact of each of these features
adjusts its predictions slightly
and we can see how much i understand i
understand so
so in the case of an image what's the
analog of average there
it's some kind of you know mushy grey of
all the images that were in the training
set or what
the output if it's classified then it
would be the
base the prior probability of that
class classify that
so it's about the output right it's not
nothing about the input
this is average yeah um by the way for
classifying
the averages in classifier by the way
but you have to specify any part of our
probabilities because otherwise the
average is absolutely meaningless
right the a priori probability of each
output
if there are 10 possible outputs digits
let's say each digit occurs with equal
frequency then the average digit
is 5 or 4.5 or whatever it is right
am i correct yeah okay
but if they don't occur with equal
frequency then obviously it's not that
that
and this is then saying so if i did a a
classifier for digits
is this is this explanation system
it's something which can deal work with
categorical data right
is that correct or is that not correct
yes
yes yes okay but so when it says the
digit
is three for example
the average digit is 4.5
the average uh probability of having a
three so
we would run one explanation for why it
thinks it's a three
we could have another explanation for
why it doesn't think it's an eight
and that's actually an example from that
that we have okay okay fine but then i
don't understand what this average is
again
okay so so in the case where it says
it's an explanation for why it thinks
it's a three what is the average
the average is what the probability for
it being a three
yes but that's not what this is five
point eight seven is nothing it's not a
probability
this is a particular number this is
about predictor it's not about
classifier
this guy's wait a minute so wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait so you're
talking about two completely different
things
one is in the case of a classifier right
you're talking about this thing is going
to um
you know there's a there's a a an a
priori probability for each
outcome
for an outcome whereas in this case
in the predictor
there is oh my gosh something completely
different
so i mean the analog of the april
priority for an outcome will be a pdf
right a pdf of outcomes
yeah but yeah right
but instead so that's the that's the
real analog of these things
i mean i i don't
okay for the classifier maybe jesse can
tell me i don't know
exactly how this works but it's it's
about
log probabilities i guess
and is it the exact okay if i take
the log probability for the class three
is it the exact same thing as the
predictor
yeah i think that should be an analog
yeah
okay so so i think what it sees so it's
better to understand it just for
prediction
so 5.8 is average
one quality and all these values
are the deviation from the average that
are implied by
each feature and if we take classifier
we would look at a specific class let's
say the class
of the digit three ed would look at the
log probability of this class and treat
it exactly like it's the predic
predicted value so we'll take the
average of the log probability of being
a 3.
that's your average and then all the
uh these sharp explanations
are the deviation from this log
probability
so in other words in that particular
case
really the thing i'm looking at is a
probability or a log probability
and this explanation so so really what
would happen there
in a sense it's you know
three arrow probability .76
and then there's a sort of an
explanation of that probability is that
correct
yes yeah actually i say look probably t
it's the
odds right really right so it's a bunch
of uh
log odds ratio or something like that
okay all right but
but the basic point here is the way to
think about this is
in in a simple-minded way we might say
there is a you know
we might have a number you know like
this where it's a plus minus thing
whereas what this is telling us
it's kind of a story of what's behind
this number
for every number and this applies only
to numbers is that correct i mean
ultimately this explanation is
about numbers so it's about
probabilities it's about prediction
values
it's about numbers correct exactly
exactly
okay so but in an image
it's somehow about probabilities of
pixels
or weights of pixels no
well what's this picture then it's it's
each pixel is a feature
so it's still about numbers it's still
about no no i
i get that i get that i get that right
but so i see what you're doing is you're
saying
i see you're computing the probability
of a particular
identification for this thing that it's
an eight with a certain probability
and then this is saying
what are the linear contributions of the
different components of that input
to contribute to this output yes
yeah i'm not sure about the linear part
but
yeah okay fine but so so then what we're
saying is
okay so what we want to get out
what is an analog of this okay
so you've got your input
and it has certain components
now you're replacing every component
with a waiting for that component i'm
curious and something like that
i'm you know when i think about some
more linear algebra
thing like or pca or something like this
or eigenvalues or something i don't
really know
to what extent can i think about
i'm a little bit confused here but i'm
trying to understand this
um you know i put in a vector
i get back these weightings when do we
find when do we have an analog of that
situation
you put in a vector and what you get
back is weightings
associated with something for that
vector like a trivial example would be a
projection
right if we say projection of
the vector four five six
on the vector one two three let's say
one minus one two
for example right that's in a sense the
components
of this vector that is saying what
components of this vector lie along
those directions
the you know what what in in the
contribution
to i'm now a little bit confused here
but but did
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah
right so i'm trying to ask of the thing
that is going to give whatever value it
is
um
um
space you know it's like fixativity to
sever in whatever space
but the result is in the output
space so to speak so it's a bit weird in
the sense that and also
a category called viable for example
it's still going
to have a numeric contribution i
understand but the reason for that is
because the real contribution is not to
the thing itself but to its brother
let's say
exactly or or pretty good value yeah
right so
i think it's actually it might be better
to think of it
in terms of conditional expectations
rather than weights because uh we don't
care we would be saying what is the
expected
predicted wine quality conditioned on
this particular acidity and
that's you know how much it and it tells
us how much the
expectation changes based on that
condition
it's true in terms of design it's a
little bit uh interesting let's say like
like the image for example
if we keep the value as they are
i wonder how we can make an email looks
good as well
and um that's a separate problem
let's worry about that in a minute first
of all we want to understand what the
heck the thing is
okay what it is is see the thing that is
confusing to me is you're saying two
different things
for a predictor you're saying these are
contributions to the actual numerical
value of the prediction
yeah right not to the pdf
of you know the contributions
see the analog would be right yeah i
understand but but
because the predictor is the is the what
is it is it the mean of the pdf or what
is it it's the expected value in the pdf
right
um yes yes i mean it depends you can
have a different utility function but
actually by default it's the mode
it's the most likely value
okay all right okay so it's the mode of
the distribution so then
then what's happening is
in the categorical case
the
i'm so confused here the categorical
case you've got a bunch of different
probabilities in a sense the mode of
this distribution
is the one you pick first it's the one
with the largest value
yes right so in this case what you're
doing is you're explaining
why that probability gets the value it
gets
right and
okay what is the analogy in the case of
yeah it's true it's two different things
i agree i agree
i don't think it is so different i think
that there's a way in which it's the
same but
we haven't quite understood it yet right
so i think i think the other case the
continuous case
is you have a probability distribution
and
you're saying the mode is being adjusted
by these
the mode is being explained by these
things its contributions to the mobile i
don't understand that i don't understand
how that works
i think you could look i think as usual
when it's in the continuous
you could connect the two by taking a
segment an interval
i think you can have the same thing as
we do for the classifier like what is
explanation for the class three
to do it with an interval on the the the
the output prediction for for predictor
for regression you say like what is the
probability
we're going to explain the probability
between the value 1 and 3.5
okay let me make a difference um okay we
have two separate functions classify and
predict
why do we have two separate functions
answer because they actually work a bit
differently
one is continuous one is discrete so my
claim is
if this property happens to be the same
property in the two cases
so be it but you know i think
conceptually it has slightly different
names
in the two cases
you see what i'm saying conceptually it
is
in one case it's the explanation for the
probability
in the other case it's the explanation
for the value am i right
or you said the odds ratio not the
probability
uh yeah yeah odd ratio yeah yeah um
and each of them i think is a is a odd
ratio
and i think that's uh yes i think that's
that's that's correct um
okay let me let me look at some of these
other ones okay so
so this is another numerical quantity
numerical thing is that correct
what one thing sorry to the to the next
in a classifier by default
it would give the explanation for the
uh predicted class that's what we were
showing before
and and in our design you will be able
to
specify which class you want an
explanation for so
by default it's uh fast it tells you is
the output
as opposed to but i mean but telling you
as the output is simply the the top
the most exactly of this exactly exactly
i mean we could say why is this pink
whatever this
is i should know i'm just not very
culturally aware about these kinds of
things
um it looks a bit pink okay well i'm
gonna guess that she has some sort of
pink
story which is why it was identified as
the possible person that that's a
picture of
um okay
um what am i trying to say here
so you're saying i can ask
why did you think pink wasn't the thing
here
yeah or yeah deviate from the
baseline probability as a way to see
right but so
for the predictor you could as well say
you've said the prediction is 3.6
tell me why it isn't 7.4 yeah you're
right
especially if you do an interval that
would uh
right but even tell me why it isn't 7.4
in other words it's like
i really wanted i really thought that i
should adjust this
i don't know why am i thinking of
autonomous tanks i shouldn't be but but
you know
whatever it is they're just this thing
to you know i estimated 7.4 but the
machine
told me 3.2
explain why you don't think it's 7.4
see what i'm saying
and that seems like as useful a thing as
why didn't you think it was pink
yeah yeah i mean yeah conceptually
it's right in practice uh predictions
are usually
unimodal and um i mean
they can be bimodal sometimes and so on
but generally
they are well explained by just their i
mean well described by just the mode
and uh where classifiers can can be like
of course they are oh we
presumably you know
learn probability i mean that the um oh
my gosh
learn distribution is what gives you the
actual shape of the distribution
is that not correct
um for for what so the
prediction of a predictor yeah no it's
actually
all the method we have they they predict
normal distributions
i see okay
yeah okay all right okay fine that's why
yeah it's usually like that
with with prediction that's why there's
often a trick
that when a distribution is multimodal
people they actually discretize the
output and then run a classifier on it
train a classifier on it all right
rather than parameterizing
let's just understand we're going to run
our time here so just to understand
what what's coming next okay
so these are alternative explanation
frameworks is that correct
yeah yeah this is a very intuitive one
i mean both of them are very intuitive
we can start with adversarial example
everybody i mean well known right find
just the closest example
or many of them that change the decision
we don't care if it's a realistic
example so you know
if you just have some weird noise or
some
blurring or some these are not real by
the way
uh just your example as you might guess
uh yeah so just what do you think so now
hold on a second i mean just like top
priorities in general we might want
multiple adversarial examples yes
i i think so yes um
yeah yeah by default it would be how to
change decision but then you could say
how to make it more
cut more you know less cut
okay okay so the neural net case you're
saying
what it'll show activations layer i
think
yeah that's going to be a completely
separate thing
uh just i don't know i haven't thought
too much about design but basically you
will specify which layer or which
neurons you want to activate and that
will show the input
plus some constraint like you need to
some constraints no no no that's not
what you want you what you want to know
is which
layer right was activated in what way
isn't this go ahead that's okay that's
depending if you
care about understanding the model or
particular decisions
so indeed what you say i think it's for
particular decisions like you give a
i mean you give an image give them why
did this thing think it was a goose
okay because layer seven had a high
degree of activation
in the in the re in the orange-ness of
its beak or whatever
yeah yeah yeah what you see here is
something different is
it's not about a particular decision
it's the model in general
let's try to understand the model so
yeah let's activate that that's
completely different that's completely
different
what we're dealing with here is is why
did you
say that basically for the model
yeah except that it can be also used to
understand the model this is why you say
that when you apply it to a test set
right you apply to a test set and then
you do statistics
but i think that's a slightly different
thing i mean the main issue is the main
pattern to all of these
is you said blah
why did you say that yeah yeah right i
mean that's yeah yeah
and so what you're saying is what you
want to do so some of these give
different kinds of output
like
right so these ones here are just
what would i have had to give for input
so that i would
what what would i give for input that is
close to the input i actually gave
that would give a different answer right
yes
exactly and these two are very connected
the only difference that counterfactuals
is trying to find
something realistic so it cannot
have i get it you know yeah um
right exactly the goat well the goat
can't
have a uh can't be some kind of alien
goat exactly
it's got to be a terrestrial goat or a
terrestrial animal of some kind
okay anyway um
yeah so it's just same thing but for
classifier measurements
and uh we can get the the explanation
for all the
uh example in the test set all right and
maybe some extra thing
there's one thing about names yeah um
because at first i wanted to
call it the full name you know shop
relative explanation but it was fine
but i realized that if we introduced
lime well the food name is local
interpretable modal agnostic
explanations
yeah it's crazy it's crazy look i mean
it's got an abbreviation that's what we
use
in many of these yeah okay yeah let's
just call it shop okay
cool
um
okay so again let's go back again to
what this is actually doing
so just like you can say for classifier
probability
okay we've got a triple-barreled thing
that can come out here
the thing it classifies it as the
probability
and the explanation for that probability
is that correct
yeah okay so what will be our way of
specifying
um i mean it could be something like
you know i mean i don't know what top
probabilities
explained or something i mean how do we
or can
or or is it the case that if i say top
probabilities here and i also
say something else what what other
property could i
put here you can you mean something
there you go uh
okay so there we go okay so fine
so you're saying that this would be
shap values here
or just it could be sharp value
or you know i guess there's many of them
yeah sharp values
um or just sharp
i think we should call it sharp values i
think it's going to be
more confusing some of these other
things are not going to be just values
yeah it's going to be distributions and
you know
because that distinguishes from
adversarial example
no i agree the only only downside
something called sharply values
which is related but different and uh
but but that's i think that's fine
that's why people can spell
i mean yeah the sharp and this sharply i
mean
you know okay so then
what we would do here
is we're feeding back into the original
format
so if the thing that was given as the
original format was a list for example
right if instead of a data set here it
was a raw list
five six eight seven five was the actual
data
that data will be replaced by the
corresponding shaft values
is that correct yes which is gonna be
the most common case
okay okay so what we're saying here
is that again the triple-barreled case
of decision
probability shop values
you see what i'm saying
how do we represent that
or don't we or do we just say top
probability sharp values to get this
list and a corresponding sharp values
list
that's that would be a lot of
i i i don't know i don't know if in
practice people are interested in
all the sharp values
well otherwise what you've got to do is
to say
something like chat value for
in in here you've got to say shot value
arrow
i like the pink one wherever
exactly that that's that was our
proposal yeah
for this so to say
to say is it like this or is it is it a
list it probably isn't a list
oh no no no it's um we
abolish the list because they are used
for having several properties
okay
like we do that for top probabilities
you can put arrow
five let's say you have the top five
and uh and yeah we also do that in
classified measurements
okay all right fine so then shot value
arrow pink
would give the shot value information
for that
yeah yeah okay right now
the remaining thing is as we push stuff
back
into the data structure that we were
given as the
actual instance how do we do that for
images
well how do we do that for audio what do
you want to do for audio
i thought i thought about that um
i mean i i i guess it would work the
same
um shady do you understand charlie do
you understand what we're talking about
here
i'm not very familiar with these okay so
what this is
is a is a sort of blame assessment for
different
attributes of the input what
which attribute was the most important
in determining the
the specified output okay so in this
case
the explanation that this was a a
an eight or something is or
wasn't a three or whatever else we're
we're assigning
blame a number in this particular case
between minus one and one is that
correct
that correct minus one to one um
no it can be it can be
more than that yeah or less than that
so it's an arbitrary value it's an
arbitrary value yeah
uh i mean if you're predicting things
are very big
which it's true give me concern for this
this image
in terms of a great idea but it's uh
all right so shoddy if we so these are
unbounded numbers positive and negative
right right so the question is is there
any reasonable way to represent that as
an image or should what we do
be to just give the array of numbers and
you can wrap image
i mean if you wrap image around an array
of numbers
that range from minus 2 to 8
to 18 what is it going to do it just
shows you stuff between zero and one
by default and you can image adjust it
if you want to
see more of it okay well that doesn't
seem like a good
thing to do by default i mean in other
words so okay to encode those values
just seems yeah i think i think they're
not going to be able to do this
right so
uh so you're concluding an image is
better i think array no no no
array is better that's what i'm
concluding right i'm concluding the
images hopeless
because although it's cute i think i
think it's necessary to
say either matrix plot or some such
other thing
around it and remember we have numeric
arrays
if we want it to be cuter than just an
array
and what does that do for us well still
can
store the numbers just just instead of a
dense array
that is large it's going to look like a
summary block
and what happens if i say array plot of
a numerical array does that work
yeah then that's what we should do
there there are a bunch of other things
that don't yet work but it's in the
pipeline
mark was working on getting arithmetic
matrix plot
matrix plot works yes okay
then i think that's a reasonable thing
and worst case you say normal of the
numerical ray
correct i think that's the right thing
to do
for uh images and audio and no idea what
we do for video
now for audio the most common feature to
use
is not the audio
the audio data it's typically mfcc that
goes in as
as features and it could have variables
to specify how large or small the mfcc
should be
in both dimensions etienne have you
given this a thought
what what should we do should we always
assume it's
mfcc with some pretty fine presets hold
on hold on i'm i'm not very confused by
something
this this thing in general
if we had an encoder a data encoder here
is this this explanation
well okay i'm sorry that so this is for
the encoder
this is before any encoding okay yeah
yeah but does it make sense for audio
to do it before any encoding because the
frequency data is very important there
yeah i haven't thought so much for audio
we probably have to have a different
case for audio okay
i don't think it's going to work for
just the array
i don't think so either
um okay all right
anything else we need to figure out for
this meeting no i think that that was it
that was it okay this is cool good
functionality
um
and uh something they've been asked
right a lot as well sounds good all
right okay people following this live
stream we are about to go to another
live stream
on geometry and graphics features
so hope to see you there thanks certain
jesse bye-bye etc later
thanks okay